mein name ist luca meine damen und
herren ich bin mal zur schule gegangen
hier denke ich auch rudi sieht es auch
bereits schon im titel eingeblendet wir
schauen uns heute mal wieder lustige
schüler antworten an von schülern die
fast so dumm waren wie ich das hier ist
eine aufgabe aus einer biologie klaußner
und die aufgabe lautet nenne sechs tiere
die ausschließlich in der arktis leben
normalerweise wird man sechs tiere
untereinander auf listen als
beispielsweise eisbären robben pinguine
et cetera alle untereinander auf listen
diese person schreibt allerdings zwei
eisbären für robben
sehr gut die nächste aufgabe ist aus
einem geschichts hieß es bei euch
geschichte bei uns gab es wirklich
einige schulen der hieß es historie
die aufgabe war auf jeden fall waren
gegen 1896 zu ende und die person
schreibt 1895
frage hier in einer 9
er war wie wird die anti baby pille und
die antwort ist sie frisst die spanien
auf
die anti baby
willis und kleiner piranha ich will gar
nicht vorstellen dass er gibt 300 + 70
plus zwei ist eigentlich eine sehr
simple matheaufgabe die jeder schüler
hinkriegen sollte jeder weiß dass da
fünf rauskommt diese personen schreibt
allerdings einfach nur hin eine menge
für gegeben
ist nicht falsch außerdem muss man bei
dieser aufgabe auch sagen das war kein
fragezeichen hinter steht das heißt
eigentlich ist es auch keine frage
und wenn es keine frage ist dann muss
man da auch nicht beantworten
nach ungefähr 20 minuten hatte die
meines erachtens nach 50 kilometer
zurückgelegt und jetzt begründet er auch
warum er das denkt und zwar das
zugrundeliegende resultat basiert auf
gedankengängen die aus subjektiver basis
entstanden
das ist wahnsinn ich bin aber ganz
ehrlich ich hab selber auch ein problem
damit meine gedankengänge wie ich auf
eine lösung gekommen bin runter zu
schreiben
in einer klausur recht nicht dann immer
aber ich rechne so voll komplizierte um
jetzt wenn zum matte geht und dann kommt
halt das richtige ergebnis raus aber
meistens habe ich erstes ergebnis und
muss dann sagen mich da hingekommen bin
noch davor
wisst ihr was ich meine ich bin ganz
ganz dumm dass stimmen in einer biologie
arbeit geht hier gefragt kann sich ein
mann mit nur einem roden fortpflanzen
die antwort ist mein mädchen finden das
unattraktiv
ich weiß dass das nicht eine richtige
antwort
das ist eine computer schluss ist aber
trotzdem wenn ein
wie kommt man denn auch so was die
antwort hier finde ich richtig richtig
süß und zwar die aufgabe begründet mit
hilfe des tierschutzgesetzes warum der
elefant kein geeignetes haustier für
dich ist und normalerweise muss man halt
jetzt mit dem tierschutzgesetz
argumentiert die person schreibt
allerdings das futter kann ich nicht im
supermarkt kaufen ich kann mit ihm nicht
zum tierarzt gehen außerdem will ich ein
pferd und der lehrer fragt halt auch nur
so und was hat das mit dem
tierschutzgesetz zu tun
ich kann mir richtig vorstellen wieder
so ein kleines mädchen geschrieben als
dass sie hat eine lehrerin auf twitter
gepostet und zwar weil die aufgabe
nennen die merkmale von ostsee und
nordsee stand da noch hinter das ist
hier ein bisschen abgeschnitten worden
leider die person schreibt bei der
ostsee ähnlicher name und spaß haben und
ob sie urlaub machen
aber auch da wieder no shit hätte bei
mir war es immer so und ich glaube das
lag auch daran dass wir im etwas
nördlicheren teil von deutschland
gewohnt haben also bielefeld liegt ja
relativ weit oben in nordrhein westfalen
bei uns war es immer so wenn man aus den
sommerferien zurück haben die alle die
irgendwie im urlaub waren man entweder
an der nordsee oder an der ostsee gab
noch ein paar coole die dann immer auf
mallorca waren auf die will man immer
neidisch aber es gab wirklich immer
diesen kampf sag ich mal zwischen den
ostsee fahrern und den nord sieben
fahrern also seid ihr eher ostsee oder
nordsee schreibt mir mal unten in die
kommentare war ich bin said nordsee das
ist meine damen und herren ist keine
lustige schüler antwort sondern ihr seht
schon oben eingeblendet das ist eine
mitteilung an die eltern der name des
schüler ist das datum und die
unterschriften wurden selbstverständlich
zensiert und das vergehen
ihr sitzt er schon eingeblendet auf dem
tisch stehen der klasse ist ein super
mensch zeigen und dabei laut zu schreien
er superman
wenn das mein sohn gemacht hätte ich
hätte im sommer 25 gegeben dass sie ist
eine aufgabe aus einem chemie test und
zwar die erste aufgabe ist nenne einen
feststoff und die person schreibt k k
dann nenne eine flüssigkeit oder
schreibt p
und eine eingabe der schreibt furz wie
[Musik]
seine aufgabe aus einem biologie test
und das war wieder so richtig süß diese
antwort also es ist natürlich klar
wieder mit dem computer geschrieben aber
ich kann mir wirklich vorstellen dass
irgendein kind weil so geschrieben hat
und zwar die ersten zellen waren
wahrscheinlich einsamen die armen
das hier ist wirklich das eine aufgabe
da dachte ich mir wieder so hey
auch der kleine luca knirps die aufgabe
hier ist schreiber ohne klammern und da
steht eine matheaufgabe in den klammern
mit einer hoch zahl dahinter man muss es
halt auseinander rechnen
die person schreibt allerdings wirklich
bei jeder verdammten aufgabe ohne
klammern hin und es ist gott verdammt
noch mal sowas von richtig wer
übersetzte eigentlich die bibel ins
deutsche
lothar matthäus
ich habe aber
hat einen unterricht damals auch gedacht
dass lothar matthäus dateien hat einer
wahrscheinlich das war auch so witzig
immer damals im lateinunterricht ich
weiß nicht wer von euch auch alles
latein hatte in der schule ich habe
bereut das zunehmend französisch wäre
glaube ich echt um einiges cooler
gewesen in dateien gibt so wie in den
meisten anderen sprachen auch drei
verschiedene änderungen für maskuline
feminin und neutrum und bei maskulin ist
es ein us am ende bei neutrum und für
weibliche person und ich mit meinem
namen durfte mir da oft echt witze
anhören das ist die nächste aufgabe und
zwar warum bestehen die meisten
kochtöpfe aus gusseisen aluminium oder
edelstahl weil sie dann nach dem ab was
schöner glänzen
genau das
das ist
exakt das ist wirklich sehr groß
so witzig da ist die frage what is love
und er schreibt runter baby don't hurt
me und me no
das ist total bescheuert er schreibt
einfach übung hin aber es ist eine
klassenarbeit das erste wort
wo ist einfach schon falsch ich habe
aber tatsächlich auch mal ein fehler
bekommen weil ich das datum falsch
geschrieben habe war das bei euch auch
damals im englischunterricht sodass lag
das einfach an meiner übel strengen
lehrerin dass wenn man das datum in
einer klausur nicht auf englisch
geschrieben hat dass man dann fehler
dafür bekommen hat gerade wenn man halt
abi klausuren hat oder vor abi klausuren
fand ich sogar noch viel schlimmer also
ganz viel in einer woche und dann kommst
du eine englische arbeit und muss dann
auf einmal das datum auf englisch
schreiben da denkt man nicht daran fand
ich zu krass hatte dir das auch oder
waren eure lehrer korrekt so das lag
einfach an mir und keiner mochte mich
was geschah an ostern jesus aufgekreuzt
exakt diese antwort in einem haus auf
innovativ und zwar war die aufgabe
joachim droll of china's immigrantin
seventeen reiterhof describing
experience ist und die person schreibt
auf chinesisch
einfach chinesische schriftzeichen
darauf muss
ist eine klassenarbeit zum thema
allgemeinwissen hat dir sowas
wir hatten nie klassenarbeiten zum thema
allgemeinwissen wer aber eigentlich
sinnvoll gewesen die weht schon die note
war sechs aber in der kreativität hat er
eine eins bekommen also wir fangen
einfach mal der erste frage in welcher
schlacht statt napoleon in seiner
letzten
die wahrheit wo wurde die
unabhängigkeitserklärung der usa
unterzeichnet unten auf der seite
das hatten wir schon beim letzten mal
und dann hier von wann bis wann gegen
der dreißigjährige krieg vom anfang bis
zum ende
was ist der haupt
als grund
heiraten solle eine pflanze verzeichnen
und zeichnen die pflanze der zelle
was ist wenn nicht zum frühstück
mittagessen und abendbrot
was sieht wie ein halber apfel aus die
andere hälfte
und was passiert wenn du einen stein in
ein gefäß mit wasser wirft ganz einfach
er widmers
wie kommt man auf so was man acht tage
ohne schlaf auskommen klar man kann noch
in der nacht schlafen so logisch kannst
du einen elefant mit einer hand heben
eine sehr interessante frage
und er antwortet es gibt keine elefanten
mit einer hand wenn du in einer hand
drei äpfel und vier orangen hass und in
der anderen hand drei orangen und viel
was hast du dann der große hessen wenn
acht männer zehn stunden brauchen um
eine mauer zu errichten wie lange
brauchen dann vier männer gar nicht die
mauer haben die acht männer schloss
gebraucht oder letzte frage weil der
liebe luxus wie kann man ein rohes ei
auf das parkett werfen ohne dass es
zerbricht wie man möchte
es ist sehr schwer hat das parkett zu
zerbrechen oder die letzte frage wie
bist du auf die antwort gekommen und er
malt einfach nachdenkt also diese
letzten antworten hier aus der klassen
dabei zum thema allgemeinwissen habe mir
den rest gegeben schreibt mir gern man
die kommentare hattet ihr einfach namens
allgemeinwissen wenn euch das video
gefallen hat dann lasse auch gerne mal
einen daumen hoch da wollt ihr einen
vierten teil lustige schüler antworten
sehen mit mir ein ich glaube ich werde
keine mehr finden
aber dann würde ich mich mal wieder auf
die suche begeben die bereits gesagt
schreib dir gerne die kommentare ob er
typen nordsee oder ostsee seit und jetzt
abonniert main kanal
[Musik]